aber die nächste frage kommt von michael
jungen wie bist du auf deinen youtube
namen gekommen hashtag frank luger und
das ist eine sache die werde ich am
allermeisten bei hashtag fragt luca
gefragt hey maschine herzlich willkommen
ich frage mich immer noch wie soll ich
das letzte mal sage wir nennen uns
untereinander immer so drei maschinen so
von der uni und sauber ich weiß nicht
wieso ich euch das auf einer trage ich
habe mir gedacht ich nehme heute mal
wieder ein frack luca video auf weil in
letzter zeit einige fragen aufkamen von
wegen wieso kam kein video oder was
hältst du von fanseiten oder wie
besoffen namen gekommen einfach so
sachen die ich einfach schon immer mal
beantworten wollte und die beantworte
ich euch heute an bei der ersten frage
an die hat mir nämlich pallaks hd
zugesendet hast du früher pokémon
gespielt herrscht extra krüger übrigens
danke das hashtag stadt lucca jetzt
immer wenn ich frage immer irgendwie in
den top drei trends deutschland bald ist
egal welcher youtuber da irgendwie noch
so drin sind oder so wenig mega dankbar
für das zeigt auf jeden fall dass ihr da
sehr aktiv seid was fragen angeht aber
erstmal tief antworten ja ich habe
früher ich werde dort angerufen von papa
ich nehme gerade auch süß hat mich
angerufen meine soja pass auf ist glatt
draußen wir kommen aus dem schwimmbad
und ist glatt draußen ich so ok ja das
interessiert mich sehr
das ist super nachdem also ja also ich
liebe pokémon seit wann sieht man seinen
eigenen schatten liebe pokémon ich habe
deswegen auch dieses spiel monster
legions angefangen wo man ja was ich
vorgestern oder so gestern hoogland mal
bitte eben twitter mit
es ist ja so ein bisschen ähnlich wie
pokémon so kann man das einfach viel
cooler aufnehmen und noch die teile
paaren und so das ist auf jeden fall
richtig cool aber ich liebe auf jeden
fall pokémon jetzt meine frage nochmal
zwei common gamer frankreich steckt
frage weißt du dass dein kind eine
animation von slammer kauf vor kommt ja
das fragen mich immer sehr sehr viele
hey wohl kommt der name wohl kommt ein
skin und solche sachen und mainz king
kommt wirklich aus diesem video von slam
account slam account nicht meinen skin
benutzt sondern ich habe den kinder aus
dem video
und zwar habe ich einfach gesehen hey
jetzt gefällt mir das ist sein team
fortress 2 spies ging mit villiger maske
finde ich richtig geil ich finde den
anzug richtig geil weil ich selber gerne
an zugetragen und deswegen
hab ich einfach den kindern damals
genommen wahrscheinlich stopp mit der
typ da hinten ist dem killer oder
deswegen habe ich ihnen den skin halt
damals genommen einfach weil der in der
animation dritten waren mir das kind
echt gut gefallen hat und wenn ihr
einfach mal / villagers trading oder
sucht dann findet ihr auf jeden fall
auch den skin von mir das ist auf jeden
fall so dass ich den daher habe und
beantwortet ja schon die frage wo san
luca wann wirst du mitkommen hd
aufnehmen ihr seid so lustig ja wir
wollten hätte mich angeschrieben und
heute jede runde aufnehmen und dann
haben wir gelabert glasfenstern haben
wir jetzt wieder paar wochen ich
geschäftlich viel irgendwie keine ahnung
warum ich kann ihn ja bald wieder
anschreiben ob der neben dem video mal
dabei sein möchte dann nämlich auch mal
wieder mit kommenden video auf tut mir
leid dass da jetzt ein zeit lang nichts
gekommen ist und auch das wetab tipp3
jahr beendet haben aber ich finde es
immer besser bevor man sich durch so ein
projekt durch gewählt dass man einfach
sagt wie es ist einfach wenn man gesagt
er hat ist uns wirklich einfach zu
schwer und dass du kannst auch
dementsprechende aber wenn ihr euch so
etwas wünscht oder wenn ihr allgemein
video wünsche habe was ich immer machen
sollte im ort vorstellen oder eine neue
serie was die komanis oder so etwas
vorstellen soll
find ich ganz cool schreibt einfach in
die kommentare nächste frage zugesendet
von ed creative lp 02 hashtags luca du
kannst dir aussuchen ein erfolgreiches
studium job oder eine für immer laufende
youtube karriere was nimmst du ich wie
das ist eine mega komplizierte frage
weil ich überhaupt nicht weiß was ich
eigentlich so später machen möchte im
leben ich weiß genau was ich studiere
und dass mir das spaß macht und alles
möglich und ich weiß auch dass mir
youtube spaß macht zumindest
hauptsächlich also es gibt natürlich mal
phasen wo man sich denkt auch jetzt
möchte ich einfach im bett liegen
anstatt jetzt noch ein video aufzunehmen
oder so aber hauptsächlich macht das ein
halt immer spaß und deswegen denke ich
derzeit würde ich mich für eine immer
gut laufen youtube player beschreiben es
kann natürlich immer mal kommen dass man
auf einmal irgendwie schwerhörig wird
oder so die oder einen autounfall
bekommt und das dann nicht mehr machen
kann und dann hätte ich natürlich schon
lieber einen gut laufenden job oder so
aber ich denke zurzeit will ich mich
echt ist eine mega schwere frage ich
kann ihn nicht beantworten bleibt ist
ein projekt oder einem youtuber was bzw
mit wem du etwas gerne machen würdest
eigentlich nicht also ich sage jetzt
nicht so verfolgt der mich die ganze
zeit was was hat er schaffte das immer
dass man dass man so bewertet wird nach
den abonnenten
damals trat auch schon wieder diese
sachen chat höhe herbstes hier hilft man
macht doch einfach ihr dass das spielt
doch einfach das spiel wir sind doch
alle einfach nur leute die hier das
spiel spielen wollen und jetzt jetzt
kriege ich ihnen halt auch noch so zehn
sekunden vorm ende
wir wollen alle zusammen das spiel
spielen und nicht darum ob ihren youtube
eine runde ist oder nicht und vor allem
dieser typische folgen ganze dreht sich
jeden moment eh gleich wieder um und
läuft wieder zu mir aber es gibt jetzt
halt kein projekt wo ich wirklich sagen
ja ich würde unglaublich gern mal da und
damit machen oder so ich weiß nicht wie
weit es jetzt ist wenn ich
dieses video hochladen aber in minecraft
leben werde ich ja auch jetzt bald
dazukommen ich hatte bisher keine zeit
und das war auch alles bisher zeit gibt
es auf jeden fall nichts wo ich sage ja
dann möchte ich unbedingt mitmachen weil
das ist der beste youtuber oder
irgendwie so ich finde einfach zu zeit
muss ich wieder von youtube finden den
ich wirklich eine regelmäßig schaut
zurzeit einfach wegen netflix seit
netflix schaue ich einfach so viel
serien obwohl das deutsche angebot recht
begrenzt ist aber dementsprechend bin
ich dann einfach nicht so youtube
süchtig mehr aber die nächste frage
kommt von michael jungen wie bist du auf
deinen youtube namen gekommen hashtag
frank luger und das ist eine sache die
werde ich am allermeisten bei hashtag
fragt luca gefragt conny woher kommt
einiges collie volcom con crafter ich
erkläre es jetzt um freunde ich möchte
euch nur sagen bitte wenn ihren kumpel
habt oder so denn ich weiß nur der name
heißt oder wenn unter einem video steht
ja worum geht es eigentlich der name
kommen bitte schreib antwortet diesen
leuten und sagt denen einfach ja hier
der hat davon ein video hochladen in
seinem frack luca video und bleibt und
da hat der genau erklärt wieder auf den
namen gekommen ist weil jetzt werde ich
euch erklären wie genau das alles mit
dem namen entstanden
dieser typ hat auf jeden fall das spiel
verstanden er stellt sich einfach nur
mitten in den weg aber hey hier fühle
mich super danke also ist eigentlich
ganz kurze geschichte viele denken immer
ich hab ein pakt mit dem teufel
abgeschlossen und ich musste mir jetzt
ein youtube kanal machen die ich
kontrakten oder irgendwie so aber es war
ganz unspektakulär und zwar hab ich
einfach damals viel kommen and conquer
gespielt und dann habe ich mir dieses
diese so hieß dieses spiel und dann hab
ich den kanal gemacht ich es konkreter
lp also konkret ob man diesen kommen
konnte und dann aussuchen konnte weil
ich dieses lpga aufgeregt hat habe ich
dann daraus einfach dieses dings gemacht
dieses konkreter weil es war halt damals
so dass minecraft wirklich nonplusultra
war und mein absolutes lieblingsspiel
natürlich mittlerweile liebe ich auch
noch minecraft und das will ich nicht
spielen einfach die ganze zeit aber es
ist auf jeden fall so dass man damals
hat unbedingt dieses dieses spiel mit
dem namen hat einen namen haben sollte
tun musste oder in lp oder mmc oder
deswegen hieß der zum beispiel noch
damals dmc schaftliche shuffle lp und so
ein paar andere sachen und ich bin
einfach begann bei konkreter gelandet
und
von von konkreter von comcom dem spiel
kommen konkret und möchte nicht sterben
ok jetzt gehts und crafter einfach von
minecraft und daher kommt mein name
superyacht kraft schreibt hashtag frank
luger würdest du bitte wieder mal pvp
auf seinem kanal bringen und so schlecht
bist du auch wieder nicht luca heiße ich
nicht mitkamen ich werde okay angenommen
abgenommen box matchbox mich ruhig ja
ich wollte auf jeden fall in zukunft
mehr pvp bringt weil ich finde ich bin
scheiß im pvp aber gerade deswegen habe
ich euch ja schon mal erklärt finde ich
daß pvp ganz cooles weil ich schlecht
bin und ich würde mir so etwas wie meine
videos wenn ich die nicht selbst machen
würde würde ich mir solche videos hat
auch sehr bald schon ich mag solche
videos die ich mir selber gerne
anschauen möchte weil das dann mein
geschmack ist mehr oder weniger und
deswegen ich habe als einziges pvp
format glaube ich minecraft triple wo
ich bebra
super special ops und haydn zig spiele
jeweils eine runde
und davon wird auf jeden fall in zukunft
mehr kommen es ist halt allerdings nur
so dass mich dieses formaten mega viel
zeit kostet also bei so einem video muss
ich wirklich nur schneiden zwischen den
fragen und ab und zu mal ran zoomen und
musik und auch sitze ich hier an unserem
video ein bis zwei stunden
aber bei triple ist es halt so da muss
ich alles mögliche zusammenschneiden
dann muss ich ja drei mitspielern 30
minuten video muss sich irgendwie auf
sieben minuten runter schneiden damit
weil keiner guckt sich in 30 minuten
video an und ich kann nicht die ganze
zeit unterhalten und gerade deswegen ist
es halt sehr sehr viel arbeit deswegen
kommt dass in letzter zeit so selten
aber es wird auf jeden fall wieder öfter
kommen wenn ich jetzt ich habe jetzt
keine klausuren mehr übrigens
klausurphase die richtig gut ich glaube
ich habe da auf jeden fall irgendwie
mehr oder weniger alle klausuren
bestanden auf jeden fall aber auch mit
guten noten glaube ich ist auch egal
jedenfalls wird in zukunft auf jeden
fall auf jeden fall auf jeden fall mehr
pvp cumarin fragt eine million abos oder
eine million euro ps du bist geil ich
glaube der furkan möchte sie eben von
screen machen oder her okay er macht
eben foto auf jeden fall eine million
euro weil wenn ich 1 millionen abos habe
dann macht das irgendwie keinen sinn
weil dann finde ich einfach eine million
abos und das ist einfach nur eine zahl
das juckt mich nicht ob das jetzt eine
million sind oder 500.000 oder wie viel
habe ich 600 irgendwas 1000 oder so und
eine million euro davon kann ich mir
sogar das equipment kauf und alles
mögliche finanzieren und gewinnspiele
machen und was weiß ich und spenden und
alles möglich ich würde auf jeden fall
irgendwie das geld dann sinnvoll anlegen
was was youtube angeht und
dementsprechend dann auf jeden fall die
eine million euro nehmen weil diese
abonnenten sind wir komplett egal also
nicht dass ihr mir egal sein aber ob da
jetzt ein millionen steht oder 1,6
millionen oder 600.000 was bist du am
dankbarsten in deinem leben fragt lena
ich bin sehr dankbar einfach für mein
leben das ich jetzt so leben kann wie
ich möchte und nicht irgendwie in irgend
einem krisengebiet aufgewachsen bin und
mich allen unterwerfen muss und schon
mit neun jahren einer waffe im krieg
liege in afghanistan und einfach gesund
lebe und nicht irgendwie in
indien oder so bei diesem bei diesem
fluss oder so wo allem anderen baden das
ist das ist einfach ekelhaft einfach
dass ich ich bin froh darüber wie ich
einfach liebe dass ich in deutschland
lebe einem sicheren start da einfach
über alles bin ich dankbar und ich finde
das sollte man auch seine frage von anne
wie findest du fan seiten / news seiten
von dir newsseiten finde ich mega geil
ich habe jetzt auf twitter
glaube ich ich weiß gar nicht wieviele
mit konkreter newsseiten es gibt aber
ich bin auf jeden fall immer offen für
jede neue weil bisher gefällt mir keine
so richtig gut und wenn die auf jeden
fall dann immer so videos posten und zu
sagen wenn ich mal was bei facebook post
aber nicht per twitter wenn die das dann
übernehmen wenn ich richtig geil
bei instagram ist es wieder so eine
andere sache und zwar bei instagram
finde ich fern seiten an sich habe ich
nichts gegen außer wenn das so
penetrante fanseiten sind und da habe
ich ein paar echt mal damals blockiert
weil da ein paar user wirklich zu weit
gegangen sind die haben dann nicht nur
mir gefolgt und hatten in ihrem ihnen in
ihrer instagram bio alles mögliche von
mir drin stehen alle informationen nein
die haben auch alle meinen freunden die
ich bei instagram habe den ich bei
instagram folge auf folgen gedrückt und
haben die angeschrieben und gefragt hey
wo wohnst du und alles und alle freunde
von mir schreiben melodica geht zur
polizei was ist das ihr von komisches
mädchen wird keinen namen sagen aber ich
dann so an als ob ich zur polizei gehe
ja die hat mich gerade gefragt wo du
wohnst und dann dachte ich mir schon so
okay es ist jetzt nicht sogar wegen also
an sich ist es in ordnung außer es ist
wirklich so penetrant irgendwie
versuchen irgendwie kontakt zu mir zu
bekommen rostocker mäßig dann bin ich da
sehr abgeneigt und kann dann schon mal
aggressiv werden aber das war es auf
jeden fall mit dieser folge hashtag
fragt luca wenn ihr fragen habt folgten
auf twitter.com von crafter und dann
will ich mich auf jeden fall über eine
bewertung vormals ein kleiner klick ist
ich hoffe ich konnte euch ein paar
sachen erst sagen wie ich heiß wie ich
auf mein namen gekommen denn woher mein
skinners sonntag allgemeinere sachen und
dann würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten video wieder einschalten
würde wenn es wieder heißt ich
beantworten eure fragen und dann wie st